PROFESSOR: If you have
potential transmission
coefficient for
a potential where
z0 is equal to 13 pi over 4.
That's a square well
of certain depth,
and we represent it in this way.
Remember n must be greater
than or equal than 2z0 over pi.
So this will be 13/2.
And 13/2 means that we can start
with n equals 7, 8, 9, and all
those.
Remember, this n counts
which bound state
of the infinite square
well you're talking about.
And the energy that you
must use are your integers,
are positive energy.
So positive energies mean that
you have sufficiently large n,
and the n that this sufficiently
large is 7 in this case.
So you can then determine
from this formula what
is the value of e n over v0.
So for example E7 over v0
turns out to be 0.15976.
E8 over v0 turns
out to be 0.514793.
And E9 over v0 is 0.91716.
So if you plot it, you have here
E, or capital energy, over v0.
And you want to plug the
transmission probability.
And it begins with 0.
That was the question
a second ago.
And then it may reach 1.
And it will reach 1 at
each one of those values.
So if, here is 1, 0.15.
There will be 0.15,
0.51, and 0.92.
So you get this, and here
another one, and here
another one.
Probability like that.
So that's a typical graph for
the transmission probability.
It oscillates, and it
reaches 1 at several points
forever and ever.
And the amplitude
become smaller,
so it's really
overall tending to 1.
So these two people
we're talking about,
Ramsauer and Townsend.
They lived from 1860s
to 1940s and '50s.
And they did their famous
experiment in 1921.
So their experiment
was elastic scattering
of low energy electrons
off of rare gas atoms.
So Ramsauer and
Townsend, in 1921,
they scattered elastically.
That means the particles
didn't change their identities.
They didn't create
more particles.
It was just electrons came
in and electrons went out.
Electrons.
And these are low
energy electrons,
off of rare gas atoms.
So these are noble gases.
Their shells are
completely filled.
And they're rather inert, very
unreactive, high ionization
energies, no low
energy states you
can scatter these atoms into.
So basically very
unreactive atom.
And you can imagine it as a
very beautiful spherical cloud.
We can draw some
electrons, there's
some protons, a nucleus
here, and an electron cloud.
So how does this
look to an electron?
Well, you know
from electrostatics
that if you have total charge
0 and it's totally spherically
symmetric, no electric
field outside.
So the electron comes
in, feels nothing.
And as soon as you penetrate
this, at any point here,
the electric field points in.
Or, well, it
actually points out,
but the electron
will feel a force in.
Because the charge
in the outside
shell doesn't produce any field.
But now, the protons
in the nucleus
beat the effect
of the electrons.
So there's a force in, a
force in, that goes in.
So basically this is like a deep
square well, or spherical well,
representing the atom.
The atom can be some
sort of spherical well
that attracts the electrons.
So what these people did were
throwing these electrons.
And they considered that
this electron scattered
a lot when they bounced back.
On the other hand,
if they continued,
if the electrons pass by, they
said nothing has happened.
So the reflection coefficient
for them, the reflection
coefficient.
Reflection coefficient
is a proxy,
a good representation for
the scattering cross-section.
So the reflection coefficient,
what they found experimentally
was a reflection coefficient,
R, that as a function of energy
was very high.
And people thought
at this moment, OK,
these are like particles
colliding with particles.
Their energies shouldn't make
much difference, you know.
You either collide or you don't
collide, and you bounce back
or you don't bounce back.
So they thought that
this would be flat.
But nevertheless, it actually
went down enormously,
and then it went up again.
So they found that for
electrons with about 1 Ev,
that's very low
energy electrons,
but they were going pretty fast.
And E1, Ev electron is
going like at 600 kilometers
per second.
So the reflection
was going like this.
And they had no explanation
why it was so sensitive
with energy, and why there would
be a funny effect going on,
that the reflection
would suddenly go down,
and just basically the
particles would get transmitted.
But if you think of reflection
here as a continuous line
and transmission
as a dotted line,
the transmission that must
alter the reflection to be 1
would be going up here and
would have reached near 1
at this value of the energy.
So the explanation
eventually was this effect,
that you should
do well and there
is a resonant effect in the
well, and for some energies
the resonance is such that it
allows the particles to just go
through and not scatter.
So this had to wait some time,
because the experiment was done
in 1921, and Schrodinger
and everybody started
doing good work in 1925, and
of wave mechanics took a while.
But eventually it was
recognized that basically it's
resonant transmission,
what is happening there.
Well, if you want to
get the numbers right,
if you want to get
that Ev better, you
have to do a spherical model of
the square, finite square well,
you have this spherical
well, and do it a little more
precisely.
But then the agreement
is pretty reasonable.